das ist nicht weniger als ein
paradigmenwechsel der esa live bei
klicks und kündigt der neue
generaldirektor der eso josef aschbacher
einen tatsächlichen kurswechsel der esa
an
seit 2006 hat die nasa die kosten
gesenkt und das entwicklungstempo erhöht
und zwar überall dort wo sie privat
unternehmen beauftragt hat technologien
und raum fahrzeuge zu entwickeln genau
das hat jetzt auch josef aschbacher vor
und kündigt in dieses projekt gestern im
livestream bei pixum vorab mit seiner
agenda 2000 25 jahren mit dabei auch in
satire astronautin anwärterin und niklas
ninas abgeordnete der grünen im
europaparlament der zu diesem webinar
eingeladen hat klicks umsatz im future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's alle herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen webinar space
race 2.0 mein name ist nicht das was ich
bin abgeordneter im europäischen
parlament und beschäftige mich da unter
anderem auch mit dem thema weltraum und
deswegen habe ich dieses webinar ins
leben gerufen und einfach mal viele
leute die sich sehr gut mit dem thema
auskennen zusammen zu bringen und über
das thema zu sprechen einfach mal zu
erörtern
wohin gehen wir eigentlich mit dem
weltraum wohin bewegen wir uns da und
vor allen dingen was kommt in zukunft
auf uns zu es werden immer mehr raketen
in den raum geschehe weltraum geschickt
und es gibt quasi ein neues space race
und es kommen beteiligte dazu von denen
man vorher gar nicht gedacht hätte dass
sie so schnell am start sind im wahrsten
sinne des wortes während es ja in meiner
kindheit war das space race noch
ausschließlich zwischen zwei nationen im
gange nämlich zwischen russland und den
usa
aber heute haben wir allen masc der ist
ja in aller munde es gibt aber auch noch
andere player nicht zu vergessen auch
die chinesen die mondmissionen nach
mondmissionen staaten die waren die
ersten die übrigens pflanzen haben
wachsen lassen auf dem mond nur ein paar
stunden dann sind sie erfroren
aber die davon auch nicht aus dem blick
verlieren da ist also
eine menge da und es geht ja auch so ein
bisschen um weltraumrecht sprich das
interessante ist auch dass man zum zum
zur einführung was zwischen nationen im
weltraum passiert das ist mit einem
weltraum vertrag alles geregelt aber und
da kommen wir an einen wichtigen kasus
knaxus was allen masc im weltraum macht
das ist überhaupt nicht geregelt
beziehungsweise gesetz wurde es sogar
erlaubt die usa und luxemburg
interessanterweise sind da im weltraum
recht ganz vorne und deshalb schwirren
auch inzwischen mehr als 1000 starling
satelliten um die erde und in den
chefetagen von spacex wird an einer
verfassung für den mars gearbeitet das
muss man sich mal vorstellen ein
privatunternehmen arbeitet an einer etwa
an einer verfassung für einen planeten
das ist schon wahnsinn aber das
wichtigste glaube ich ist und nicht nur
weil raketen so gut für das klima sind
wir brauchen dringend weltraumfahrt wir
jetzt unsere zivilisation ist eigentlich
ohne weltraum und satelliten und
raumfahrzeuge nicht mehr denkbar
es gibt ja das poco pokus programm der
esa zum beispiel was unglaublich wichtig
ist was wahnsinnig viel daten uns
liefert über die erde über den
klimawandel über die entwicklung des
meeresspiegels sind sie beide frau
thiele eich und herr aschbacher sie sind
ja meteorologen wie ich aber anfang
gelernt habe und sie können das am
besten beurteilen ohne satelliten werden
wir relativ blind und und eben auch
raumfahrt ist es wahnsinnig wichtig dass
wir das haben um auf unsere erde zu
gucken aber es gibt noch ein paar punkte
die waren sich wichtig sind und deshalb
ist ihnen musk ja so daran und er ist
neben stephen hawking ein großer
verfechter der these wenn wir unsere
spezies schützen wollen wenn wir
überleben garantieren wollen müssen wir
uns eigentlich im weltraum ausbreiten
denn diese gefahren sind ja nicht um
reale und wir haben es gerade auch im
trailer der esa gesehen wenn ein großer
asteroid auf unserer erde einschlägt
dann kann er hier zu einem massensterben
führen dass auch uns menschheit unserer
menschheit betrifft das kann auch der
ausbruch eine super vulkans sein und all
das ist ja hier auf dem planeten schon
passiert also es gibt so viele dinge
warum wer ohne raumfahrt nicht
existieren können dass man ja dass das
eigentlich unvorstellbar ist und herr
aschbacher ich hoffe ich habe ihnen
damit eine frau thiele einen roten
teppich jetzt mit diesem anfang
statement ausgerollt es ist fantastisch
der krach gehört das ist unglaublich was
das was da an faszination ausgeht und
die sind absolut richtiger wenn wir
keine satelliten hätten dann gebe es
sehr viele dinge überhaupt nicht
die metrologie wurde erwähnt 80 prozent
der daten für die tägliche
wettervorhersage kommen aus der berliner
und diese satelliten die entweder im
geostationären orbit cent oder im pool
herum fliegenden orbitz sind die liefern
massenhaft daten für die tägliche
wettervorhersage aber auch für andere
aber ganz wichtige informationen
es wurde kopernikus erwähnt ja ich
zufällig bevor ich generaldirektor der
eso wurde weil ich zuständig für
erdbeobachtung und kopernikus ist eines
der programme das sich seit dem ersten
tag aufgebaut habe
es hat 20 jahre gedauert um so was auf
die beine zu stellen
aber kopernikus ist wie ganz richtig
gesagt wurde das beste programm um
unseren planeten zu überwachen und
dadurch zu schützen und genau das wollen
wir machen mit unserem weltraum durch
technologien dass wir die technologie so
einsetzen dass wir unseren leuten
unserem planeten helfen zu überleben
aber auch besser zu verstehen was
eigentlich alles passiert das komplette
kursprogramm ist derzeit der
goldstandard beachtung und unsere
freunde der nasa und japan in russland
in china sehen wirklich mit begeisterung
auf unsere daten und unsere programme
und wollen mit uns zusammenarbeiten wo
wir nicht mehr juniorpartners sehen
sondern wirklich
der senior partner aber einfach höher
das beste programm in diesem bereich auf
die beine gestellt haben was sie kann
nur bestätigen was was gesagt wurde es
ist ohne weltraum kann man sich das
leben so nicht mehr vorstellen was wir
hier sehen ist wirklich was die leser
macht und wie die esa aufgebaut ist ich
werde jetzt nicht in die einzelnen boxen
gehen oder in unserer organigramm aber
nur um zu sagen dass wir von der von der
wissenschaft von der vom universum
bisher über die erde eigentlich alles
beobachten und unsere technologien
einsetzen
ein anderes beispiel das wurde vorhin
angesprochen mit elon musk ist die ganze
kommerzialisierung
das ist richtig in amerika die zwei
reichsten länder jeff bezos sonder elon
musk investieren will die arten dollars
pro jahr in den weltraum sp6 ist
natürlich bestens bekannter bauch jeff
bezos mit blue origin als wird enorm
viel geld ausgegeben und das sind nur
zwei menschen in amerika wenn und da
sieht man auch dass europa nicht
vergleichbar ist mit amerika was die
investitionen aus dem privaten segment
betrifft aber was braucht man dafür
um das zu voranzutreiben und das ist
auch herzstück meiner agenda 2025 die
ich bei amtsantritt am ersten märz auf
den tisch gelegt habe man braucht
talente und von denen gibt es in europa
unmenge viel talent mit leute mit
fantastischen ideen
diese ideen umzusetzen ist natürlich die
herausforderung dafür braucht es geld
und dafür braucht es prozesse die
einfach schnell gehen geschwindigkeit
steht hier aber was gemeinde sind
wirklich prozesse wo man einfach schnell
auch mit risiko etwas ausprobieren kann
und aus den aus diesen erfahrungen
stellen lernen kann um ideen wirklich
stellung zu setzen
ich habe er gern der 2025 erwähnt das
ist eigentlich mein buch das sich
derzeit finalisiert mit meinem
mitgliedsländern auch mit meinen stab im
haus um zu zeigen wo die esa in den
nächsten jahren hingehen wird ich will
nicht ins detail gehen aber was wir
wirklich erreichen wollen ist die esa
und die weltraum in europa gemeinsam mit
dem partner mit
den mitgliedsländern mit der
europäischen kommission mit dem
europäischen parlament einen schritt
weiter zu bringen aber so einzusetzen
dass sie wirklich für den menschen da
ist und den menschen hilft haben vorhin
bei der kommerzialisierung das wort grün
gesehen und das wurde nicht eingefügt
hier weil wir mit herrn die naz
diskutieren sondern das ist wirklich in
meiner agenda ganz eng verankert dass
wir klima nachhaltigkeit als kernfragen
und so die digitalisierung und der
einsatz von weltraumtechnologie
verstehen und genau das wollen wir
wollen wir machen diese visionen die
hier aufgezeigt wird in diesem bild ist
wirklich befindet nicht ins detail gehen
aber was ich erreichen will ist dass
europa sich richtig positioniert
zwischen amerika zwischen china wo
wahnsinnig viel geld investiert wird in
die raumfahrt europa hat im vergleich
dazu fiel weniger zum beispiel europa
gibt ein siebtel des geldes aus von
amerika hat aber trotz alledem eine ob
gute kapazitäten und um hier nicht
zurückzufallen und weiterhin
wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben muss auch in
europa investiert werden und ich will
einen politischen dialog mit der
kommission mit dem parlament mit den
mitgliedsländern initiieren und weiter
forcieren um diese diskussion diskussion
voranzutreiben damit europa sich bewusst
wird was will europa machen den weltraum
wo müssen wir hingehen was sind die
prioritäten und wie kann man das
erreichen und zum schluss noch zwei
leute die eigentlich diese inspiration
auch des weltraums symbolisieren das
hier ist ein slide das den astronaut
kohl beschreibt den wir am 16 februar
angekündigt haben am 31
märz wird der call auf gemacht man kann
sich bewerben alle jungen damen und
herren quer durch europa können sich
bewerben astronaut astronauten zu werben
zu werden das ist fantastisch ein
kindheitstraum praktisch für für viele
oder für mich war es auch ein
kindheitstraum und das ist der corbett
dann offen sein bis zur ende april und
dann wird durch verschiedene
auswahlverfahren werden neue astronauten
in europa ausgewählt wir haben auch und
das ist das erste mal überhaupt weltweit
einen korb barra astronauten das heißt
astronauten kandidaten wie
der körperlichen behinderungen die wir
auch gerne aufnehmen wollen natürlich
müssen wir diese behinderungen
kompliziert oder sehen wie wird wie das
im weltraum eingesetzt werden kann
eventuell müssten veränderungen auch in
der raumstation oder wo auch immer
gemacht hat ist möglich zu machen die
müssen natürlich geistig topfit sein
haben aber vielleicht eine körperliche
behinderung und das ist etwas was was
wir machen um wirklich auch zu zeigen
dass weltraum wirklich für alle da ist
und dass alle sich begeistern können
alle sicher für diesen astronauten job
bewerben können
aber vorher haben wir zwei astronauten
die heuer noch auf die raumstation
fliegen werden auf der rechten seite
sehen sie noch mal bis g thoma wird ende
april mit einer space sechser crew
dragon kapsel auf die raumstation
fliegen und dann ein halbes jahr später
auf der linken seite matthias maurer aus
deutschland der ihn dann ablösen wird
aber es wird eine kurze zeit geben wo
sie überlappen sind also beide in der
raumstation sind und matthias wird dann
später ein halbes jahr später von einer
weiteren europäerin von samantha
cristoforetti abgelöst werden die anfang
nächstes jahr starten wird
mit diesem wir haben mit diesem
symptomatischen bild zwei europäische
astronauten vor einer falcon 9 rakete
da sind wir beim thema denn space ex ist
der einzige
neben den russen der einen regelmäßigen
flugbetrieb zur internationalen
raumstation am laufen hat und dazu muss
man sagen das kriegt space ex nahezu mit
allen der mit der regelmäßigkeit einer
taxifahrt hin
das funktioniert alles wie am schnürchen
und dass es extrem beeindruckend während
da sind wir auch wieder bei der nasa die
polen-beauftragte orion-kapsel die iss
verfehlt hat sprich die ist auch noch
lange nicht flugbereit und währenddessen
und da sehen wir zum einen die chancen
aber auch ich sag mal so die problematik
testet ihre maske munter weiter seinen
starship und macht testflug am testflug
inzwischen ist das schwesterschiff in
der lage ohne in die luft zu gehen
jedenfalls bei der landung direkt in die
luft zu gehen wieder auf der erde zu
landen
und wenn ein raumschiff in der lage ist
auf der erde zu landen dann ist es für
ein raumschiff viel viel leichter auf
dem mond zu landen
sprich imas entwickelt gerade eine
rakete die in der lage ist von der erde
zu starten
zum mond zu fliegen und dort auch direkt
zu landen man muss dazu allerdings sagen
was da im moment ständig in die luft
gejagt wird
korrigieren sie mehr beherrschbare wenn
ich da falsch liege ist eine blechdose
mit triebwerken unten dran und paartanz
drin
das ist natürlich kein richtiges
raumschiff aber zu was das in der lage
ist das ist schon absolut beeindrucken
und das und da sind wir beim thema und
da sind wir auch beim thema ariane 6
das macht er unglaublich kostengünstig
und sieht auch so aus als würde das
starship für wahrscheinlich gerade mal
pro stadt 100 millionen dollar in die
luft gehen und als die ariane-5 jetzt
schon teurer und die ariane 6 wird
zumindest wahrscheinlich nicht billiger
als eine falcon 1
und da stehen wir halt vor der
herausforderung dass die raumfahrt
unbedingt billiger sein werden muss oder
preiswerter und der apparat genau das
thema auch schon ins auge gefasst bei
spacex gibt es keine großen strukturen
da gibt es nicht ist ich hab natürlich
nicht den internen blick ich behaupte
mal jeden tag zehn meetings sondern da
gibt es meeting und dann sagst elon musk
machen und das spart natürlich
wahnsinnig viel geld wenn einer die
macht hat zusagen machen und das ist so
ein bisschen bei der esa das ganz ganz
große unter die ganz ganz große
herausforderung gibt der zahlreich es
gibt ja nicht nur die esa es ist gibt
die dlr
es gibt eine französische
raumfahrtagentur es gibt eine
italienischen raumfahrtagentur und alle
reden mit und alle wollen natürlich
entscheiden und kein geld soll verbrannt
werden was natürlich dazu führt dass
geld verbrannt wird in diesen strukturen
ich lasse mir gerne ins wort fallen von
den satelliten
ich werde ganz ganz kribbelig dabei mir
ich erinnere mich gerade unsere reisen
2018 lieben gefüttert und vielleicht
noch mal dazu also ich bin ein kind dass
meine kindheitserinnerungen sind voll
und der esa ich habe esa und der
schlagstock und mit meinem schrank seit
20 also stapelweise ich trage es basics
pulli und wir waren bewahren weil also
ich was ich damit sagen wollte ich bin
quasi in der staatlichen raumfahrt groß
geworden und ich finde es wahnsinnig
schwierig so auf der einen seite zu
sagen was perfekt macht es super und
dann auf der anderen seite zu sagen ja
die esa großer zu viel geld weil ich mal
sind einfach zwei komplett
unterschiedliche dinge und machen wir
uns nichts vor sex hat das geschafft
wenn sie von der nasa geld bekommen
haben das ist etwas also sex hätte auch
nicht alleine das geschafft was die
geschafft hätten sie haben es geschafft
weil den bedarf durch eine staatliche
agentur da und das ist das was ich
probiert habe vorhin schon anzudeuten
also ich sehe die riesen chance dass man
zusammen
einfach die kommerzialisierung also dass
das die raumstation kommerziell genutzt
werden soll ist jetzt auch hunt ständer
aber und dass man das aber gemeinsam mit
der staatlichen agentur macht als ich
und ich finde dass wir sehen in der
raumfahrt
das ist eine wahnsinns geschwindigkeit
hingegen gehandelt wurde dem 2018 lassen
wieder das war nicht gekehrt 2009 10
wurde die raumstation wir können uns
geöffnet so richtig genutzt wurde es
noch nicht aber das sind
geschwindigkeiten für staatliche
regierungsapparat wenig ziemlich
beachtlich bin und ich finde man merkt
auch der wille ist da dann hin zu gehen
besonders auch den usa ich bin auch ein
fan von der art von der herangehensweise
von 2006 gewann die u bahn bau hin und
wenn man eine woche später bei ist
welche sex und bedurften jeweils die
werke gehen und das ist einfach komplett
anders das ist ein kompletter
unterschied gering ist viel regulierter
entspricht vielmehr einer staatlichen
agentur als expo die vom joghurt
maschine ungelogen einfach mal gab es 20
meter weiter vom triebwerk steht das ist
kein scherz dass das ist wahr wenn man
von boeing kamen etwa aus trier und muss
ich auch sagen und es ist deswegen ist
es ja auch so wichtig dass hier die
bereits existierenden staatlichen
agenturen mit den an mit dem
kommerziellen an der zusammenarbeit
dann kann man das
im schlimmsten fall ist nämlich so dass
ist irgendwann zu einem ungleichgewicht
gelangen nur noch und dann wird es
berlin als kläger und so wie es jetzt
schon ist gucken wir uns doch mal an den
gesang kommerzielle kommt wenn man das
so nennen möchte
die waffengleichheit japaner es ist ein
reicher billiarde aus dem oder
billionaire aus den usa es sind reiche
meistens männer die es sich leisten
können einfach zu sagen ich brauche
jetzt fertig was ist mit wissenschaft
auf kommerziell gibt es nicht gibt es
nicht ist nicht existent
da sind wir das einzige projekt das mit
new york probiert geld zusammen zu
kriegen weil dafür einfach auch gerade
kein geld da ist aber man möchte das
nicht dafür ausgeben und das ist etwas
wo ich ganz ganz deutlich sagen möchte
man kann jetzt hier nicht sagen
die regierung alle staatlichen agenturen
ihr macht das irgendwie ja die macht das
alles geht so langsam und schaut ob man
einfach nur hier weil sie können ja gar
nicht anders es gibt verwaltungsapparate
es gibt bestehende regeln und die müssen
eingehalten werden
passiert das darf halt kein geld
geschmissen werden das ist einerseits
natürlich extrem vernünftig aber
andererseits ist es auch ein hemmschuh
und deswegen fand ich dann sehr
interessant dass dr sprache gesagt hatte
hey das muss schneller gehen da müssen
sachen flyer auf personen konzentriert
werden oder es ist ja natürlich kann man
das nicht aber es ist gutes vor der
schwierigkeit ist wenn die asse jetzt
anfängt zu arbeiten
ich befürchte in spätestens zwei jahren
kein geld mehr bekommen
die schwierigkeit die ich sehr
vielleicht kann ich da wirklich was
einbringen dass die meisten ist die
diskussion fantastisch ich finde das
wirklich gute herr kraft über sie
ansprechen diese eigentlich spricht mir
eigentlich aus der seele
dass man in europa wettbewerbsfähiger
sein bus und werden muss oder schneller
agieren müssen taucher mehr risiko
eingehen muss und auch wer bereits sein
sollte von herkömmlichen zusammen mit
konventionellen methoden weg zu gehen um
wirklich diesen wettbewerb schaffen zu
können
aber nur ganz kurz sowie hat sp 6
geschafft so erfolgreich zu sein
sb 6 hat es nur deshalb geschafft weil
spacex in summe bisher mehr als zehn
milliarden us-dollar bekommen hat von
der nasa und man muss sich mal
vorstellen zehn milliarden dollar ist
eine menge geld mit 10 milliarden kann
man bisher
wettbewerbsfähige rakete bauen und
natürlich dann alle zehn tage ins
weltall schießen
der zweite punkt und da das
unterscheidet amerika von europa in
amerika hat es letztes jahr oder listen
paar jahre 40 raketenstarts pro jahr
gegeben 40 in china geht auch etwas 40
in europa gibt es fünf das heißt europa
hat einfach keinen vergleichbaren markt
an der satellitenstart oder ketten starz
dh es gibt auch keine firma in europa
sagte nicht so viele starts habe 40 pro
jahr was er in x geld sehr viel geld ist
dann nämlich das risiko auf mich zu
investieren und eine eigene rakete zu
bauen und das ist ein riesen unterschied
den wir in europa nicht haben sowas muss
europa machen und glauben sie mir dass
ich mir da wirklich gedanken gemacht
habe bevor ich generaldirektor wurde das
sind dokumentiert das nennt sich agenda
zu das 25
und das beschreibt genau das was sind
die schwächen europas heute oder
umgekehrt was muss europa machen um in
diesem segment auch eine rolle spielen
zu können trotz anderer
rahmenbedingungen und da gelangt nicht
zu ausführlich sein aber was europa
machen muss ist erstens ganz richtig wie
sie gesagt habe wir krachten eine eine
andere strategie fahren wo wir auch mehr
risikobereitschaft eingehen wo wir mehr
wettbewerb zulassen und die privaten
firmen fördern nämlich so fördern dass
sie sich wirklich entwickeln können was
die nase gemacht hat und das war
wirklich sehr clever ist irgendwann
haben sie nach dem spaceshuttle
beschlossen das war 2006 das hier eine
ganz neue strategie machen und zwar
nicht mehr so wie bisher der
space-shuttle entwickeln und ein flug
einige hundert millionen dollar pro flug
gekostet hat wie sie wie sie wissen dass
sondern es hat gesagt nein wir machen
ich habe beides gemacht hier weiterhin
raketen entwickelt über dem er verstehe
zwar private aber wer die boeing
organisationen oder firmen zum anderen
deshalb parallel dazu werden wir einfach
geld auf den tisch legen und wir
garantieren dass wir private von
privaten anbietern launchers kaufen wenn
die natürlich gewisse qualitätsmerkmale
haben und und gewisse kriterien erfüllen
und da konnte sich space extern
entwickelt aber mit massiver massiver
unterstützung finanziell und
technologisch von der nasa und das ist
gut für für spacex europa muss auch in
der richtung europa muss auch der
erstens den privaten wettbewerb zulassen
zum anderen auch den firmen die sich
kommerziell entwickeln wollen den raum
lassen und auch die möglichkeiten
schafft das zu tun und das passiert
jetzt gerade in deutschland drei in
deutschland gibt es drei firmen die
private raketen bauen
ich will sich beim namen nennen um das
ist werbung für firmen zu machen
aber die sind wirklich interessant und
die sind doch nicht so weit die fliegen
doch nicht dass wirtschaft noch zwei
jahre dauern bis die den ersten start
haben
aber was die an konzepten anbieten ist
hat sich in kurzer zeit sehr schnell
entwickeln was muss europa jetzt machen
europa muss für diese neuentwicklungen
diese neuen unternehmen möglichkeiten
schaffen dass wir deren start auch
kaufen wenn die durchstarten und keiner
kauft sie dann kommen sie nicht auf dem
markt und das ist teil meiner strategie
auch dass wir hier auch ehrlich wie die
nazis gemacht hat und zur strategie
ändern und auch solche firmen ein kunde
sind dann solche staat kaufte mit
solcher wettbewerb sich entwickelt und
das ist für mich der schlüssel zum
erfolg auch in europa dass wir schneller
sind kommerzieller werden und auch
solche für den wettbewerb ganz einfach
fördern und nicht nicht immer oder nicht
unbedingt nur die staatlich geförderten
betriebe finanziert das ganze webinar
gibt es auf dem kanal von niklas ninas
in voller länge und demnächst noch mehr
zur raumfahrt und vor allem auch zum
weltraumrecht sehr sehr spannend also
hier anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
da könnt ihr vor allem mit jemand
diskutieren der dann auch entscheidungen
maßgeblich mit beeinflusst also los
geht's
das auf jeden fall bis dann bleibt dran